I'd like to continue
our work together.
So why don't you come to
Prague with me, Jakob?
Maybe I could get you a
position at the University.
We'd have time to work
on accelerated motion.
Albert, I am flattered.
But I've received another offer.
A [inaudible]?
No, assistant
to Philipp Lenard.
Well, Lenard's a genius.
Of course, you must accept.
Yes, but he's got a bit of a
reputation, quite a taskmaster,
apparently.
Honestly, I get a pit in my
stomach just thinking about it.
I know how you feel.
In Salzburg, I was so
nervous before my lecture,
I thought my heart was going
to stop right in the elevator.
Actually, I imagined
something very strange.
So the elevator was falling, and
I was just floating inside it.
It was terrifying at first,
but then, suddenly, it was
as if I had no weight at all.
Because a falling man does
not feel his own weight.
Me, the floor, my papers were
all falling at the same rate.
So I couldn't feel the pressure
of the floor on my feet.
But what if the
elevator was rising?
I'd be accelerating in
the opposite direction.
It would produce
the opposite effect.
You'd feel the floor.
I'd be glued to
it, as I am now.
That's gravity.
Exactly.
I should've seen it before.
This is so simple, so beautiful.
Acceleration and gravity
are the same thing.
This is the idea I've been
missing to complete relativity.
This may just be one of the
happiest thoughts of my life.